the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of eight news now or next our
media group
i think they're scared they're concerned
or they feel under assault i see the
rise of cancel culture
tonight on politics now the senate race
heats up the republican adam blacksalt
enters the race and the democratic
machine starts moving
chaos in kabul the efforts to get
americans and afghan refugees out and
the push to help those who helped the
united states in the last 20 years of
war plus
without it we really have nothing
shortage on the colorado river after an
historic declaration what we're going to
break down rather what cuts mean for
lake mead and where water from the
shrinking river is really going
from 8 news now this is politics now
thank you very much for joining us here
on politics now i'm john langler the
field is being set now for the 2022
senate race here in nevada former
attorney general adam laxalt is now
officially a candidate he launched his
campaign this week with a heavy with a
culture war rather heavy ad
in our house and at our church we talk a
lot about what's right and what's wrong
and right now it seems like the wrong
side is winning
the radical left rich elites woke
corporations academia hollywood and the
media they're taking over america that's
your empire right there telling lie
after live
so again that is a political ad from the
lax alt campaign the ad did not talk
about nevada specifically laxal has the
support of the national republican
establishment though incumbent democrat
catherine cortez masta was the first
latina elected to the senate here from
nevada in 2016. lax salt meanwhile is an
ally of former president trump he lost
his bid for governor to steve sisolak in
2018. the i-team's david charns caught
up with laxalt this week to ask about
the race
[Applause]
the senate uh you know who knows what
the composition is going to be but
minority leader mitch mcconnell voted
for infrastructure
so sort of going against it is going
against
a lot of the
the party
republicans supported this i think you
know 17 19 republicans supported this so
what about it don't you like besides the
the cost
look i i'm running to be an independent
voice for that i'm running to be someone
who's actually just going to stand up
consistently for them and right now you
know masto just stands with her party 99
of the time she votes with chuck schumer
and so okay if if mitch mcconnell
supported this one
i still don't support it and i'll make
those judgment calls each time for what
i think is right and like i said must be
very clear i would have been pushing
to get a more narrow bill a bill that
only included bridges and roads and
truck and tunnels but people really
believe are infrastructure this bill was
a christmas list of lots of other
liberal wish lists from washington and
unfortunately we can't afford it what is
it
that she hasn't done that you feel hey
i'd do a better job
i flipped the question on you what has
she done
um i i i challenge you you know get on
the street i'm looking talking to your
to your listeners right now
what has she done for nevada and not
just five years as a senator eight years
as an attorney general 13 years what are
the things that come to your mind that
she's done for nevada and i promise you
i speak to people every day people can't
think of anything
because
she hasn't done anything for nevada
certainly as an attorney general there's
no signature thing that she did and and
we had to go in and clean up her mess
that she left in the attorney general's
office
and it's something that i anticipate
we're gonna have to do if i win this
senate race we're gonna have to go in
there and start delivering results for
our state
should we accept afghan refugees there
are thousands of detainees at the bagram
prison that were released and that are
out and we have an open border that
senator masto is refusing to fight to
secure
and our country is most certainly less
safe today than it was one week ago
without release and so that is a big
priority and something that we need
answers to uh what are we going to do
about these thousands of really bad
folks that have been released into the
international terrorist network back in
november uh you had the press conference
that there was tons of election fraud
those claims were thrown out of state
court federal court
members of your own party said there was
no fraud
the secretary of state released a report
and found
24 cases of potential fraud that were
forwarded to your former office the ag's
office
was this election fraudulent
i have said from the beginning and i
maintain today that mail-in balloting
was not ready for prime time it was not
going to be a safe
means of election for our state we had
never done it before and it takes states
years and years and years to get that
right
putting mail-in balloting which the
democrats did with no republican votes
three months out before election was not
wise and it was not something that was
ever going to give voters confidence and
so i focused on mail-in signature
verification from beginning to end and i
still maintain that mail-in balloting
was not secure in fact i don't know that
anybody argues that there was not fraud
in mail-in balloting the question is to
what degree
and the answer is we still don't know
lax salt was the campaign chair for
president donald trump and said he would
welcome his endorsement for more of
david's interview with mr laxalt you can
head to 8newsnow.com now other
republicans in the senate race include
former miss nevada shirelle mendenhall
and wounded warrior sam brown you can
see our interview with ms mendenhall on
8newsnow.com as well we plan to speak
with mr brown on politics now very soon
democratic groups quickly gathered to
denounce laxalt's announcement and that
included the bosses of several labor
unions their first focus laxalt's
opposition to that infrastructure bill
who in their right mind would take a
stand against putting nevadans to work
putting food on their tables and keeping
a roof over their children's head
i'll tell you who adam laxalt and his
main political benefactor the former
president trump
the nevada afl-cio carpenters electrical
workers and other unions were all at
that press conference earlier this week
promoting the infrastructure bill
democratic campaigns including miss
cortes masto's re-election campaign
they're being run through a new
political arm for the state called
nevada democratic victory
also this week clark county district
attorney steve wolfson announced his
re-election campaign wolfson was first
appointed to the position back in 2012.
in his campaign launch he touted
diversion programs and a unit that
reviews inmate claims of innocence mr
wolfson's drawn criticism from fellow
democrats for his support of the death
penalty former state lawmaker and
prominent las vegas defense attorney
ozzie fumo tells 8 news now he will run
against wolfson fumo is an opponent of
the death penalty
also this week nevada republican party
chairman michael mcdonald was appointed
to the rnc's 2024 presidential
nominating process committee mcdonald is
also on the presidential debate
committee
the first federal water shortage along
the colorado river is now in effect
today lake mead is at its lowest point
ever
1067 feet federal water managers believe
the level will keep on dropping sparking
this declaration so this is tier one of
these cutbacks that means nevada arizona
and mexico will have all have the
maximum amount they can take out of the
river cut back the hardest hit with the
first round of these cuts will be
arizona
farmers in the three central counties in
arizona pima county
maricopa county and pinal county will be
losing
uh substantial portions of their surface
water
they will be able to pump some amount of
groundwater
under our 1980 groundwater management
act
i mentioned we also have one tribe and a
couple of cities who will lose a small
very small amount of their water
so let's break this down let's talk
about what this means for us here in
nevada nevada is allowed three hundred
thousand acre feet of colorado river
water every year but we only actually
use about two thirds of that or so about
235 000 acre feet per year even though
our allotment could go down to 279 000
acre feet we're still short of that
maximum in fact we could go through the
next four tiers of cutbacks and that
would still only drop us to about 270
000 acre feet which is still more than
we actually use right now
in a normal year seven and a half
million acre feet of colorado river
water is allocated to seven states and
again mexico nevada's share is less than
two percent the biggest users are
california and colorado for example
imperial valley california uses 10 times
what we do
the imperial irrigation district is the
single largest user on the entire
colorado river basin we're in the
southeastern corner of california our
use is primarily agricultural the both
the uh
the nice juicy steak and the fluffy
salad you have during the year that is
most likely from the imperial valley or
surrounding region here and so we're at
the tail end of the system here almost
on the border with mexico
and so to us the colorado river is a
hundred percent of where water comes
from and without it we really have
nothing
well las vegas is so good at conserving
water we're trying to get everyone else
to follow our lead the southern nevada
water authority is helping california
set up its own water recycling program
this week a ruling in an immigration
case by a federal judge in nevada could
have some national repercussions judge
miranda dew ruled a federal law about
illegal re-entry into the u.s is
unconstitutional and it may be the first
federal ruling of its kind judge dew
says it has racist origins and
disproportionately impacts latinx people
the case centered on a man that was not
a u.s citizen who was originally
deported in 1999. in 2019 he was
arrested again for being a quote
deported alien found in the united
states well that crime makes up 30
percent of all federal criminal charges
back in 2019
the doj has not indicated if it will
appeal just yet
next on politics now chaos in
afghanistan we'll have a look at the
efforts to try and get americans out as
the war ends and the taliban takes back
control and a recap of the california
gubernatorial recall debate coming up on
politics
welcome back to politics now
in afghanistan the pentagon now says it
has evacuated 14 000 people from kabul
in the past week that is much lower than
the goal initially of evacuating 7 000
people a day but president joe biden
says they would evacuate every american
who wants to go home the military will
nevada senator catherine cortez masto
has joined a call for more special
immigrant visas for afghan translators
who helped the military in the last 20
years of war republican congressman rob
whitman says it's important to help
those who helped us
there are so many
sid applications special immigrant visa
applications that the state department's
just overwhelmed we encourage
everyone that is there in afghanistan
trying to get out to pursue both of
those
processes in unison
and all week long our washington dc
correspondent kelly meyer kelly let's
just get right into things what's been
the reaction on capitol hill to the
unfolding developments overseas
well hey there a lot of criticism for
president biden on this withdrawal we
knew that this was coming we knew that
he set this goal to have all troops out
of the region by the end of august by
the anniversary of september 11th the
20th anniversary
but as we saw in the past week
this takeover from the taliban in these
areas eventually reading kabul and now
this uh you know swift evacuation or
attempt to evacuate americans and afghan
allies that helped the us military along
the way in the past 20 years facing a
lot of questions the administration is
right now from a lot of lawmakers both
democrat and republican here on capitol
hill some who agreed with the decision
to withdraw others who did not agree or
are just criticizing the way that the
administration went about it they're
saying it's not that he made the
decision to leave it's how they're going
about this withdrawal and how they are
apparently that they say they weren't
set up to bring these amount of troops
home get people out in time before the
taliban took over well kelly there's
that's the political i guess discussion
on capitol hill the republicans the
democrats the white house having their
own uh finger-pointing match but there's
the human cost as well not only the
americans who are there the troops uh
the defense the defense contractors etc
but the refugees how many refugees
might end up or will eventually end up
here in the u.s and where do things
stand with the effort to get them from
afghanistan over back into the u.s
well that's just the thing and that's a
good question because we just don't know
the numbers i was just inside the
pentagon briefing this week and you know
they couldn't really answer the the
amount of american citizens or afghan
allies that have been brought home they
said it was you know 7 000 this week but
they couldn't break down the numbers of
who that 7 000 number of evacuees were
were they americans were they afghan
allies were they refugees who's getting
out what
applications still need to be processed
for some of these visas for those
translators that help the us
some of them are still in process some
are being moved to other regions or
being brought to the u.s so there's a
lot of unanswered questions with this
somewhat
swift take over as some would say of the
taliban of this region and how the u.s
is reacting to making sure that
americans get out we really haven't had
a definitive answer from the pentagon on
whether this date will be extended that
august 31st date the president said this
week that they want to make sure that
all americans are out and they won't
leave until all americans are out but
the pentagon did say pentagon press
secretary john kirby did say that that
would require an additional conversation
with the taliban if they decide to stay
beyond august 31st
and that was kelly meyer from our
washington d.c bureau governor steve
sisilak's office says it is committed to
accepting refugees and immigrant visa
holders from afghanistan
switching gears fiery moments in
california as a recall election draws
near this week the second debate among
those hoping to replace governor gavin
newsom took place conservative talk show
host larry elder leads the polls but he
skipped out he was criticized by san
diego mayor kevin faulconer for comments
saying uh women quoting here women don't
know as much as men and that it's okay
to discriminate against pregnant women
in the workplace
another weird debate moment as candidate
john cox was served comments during his
opening remarks
the recall election in california is
september 14th
next on politics now redrawing nevada's
congressional districts
it really sets up the balance of power
in terms of those four who gets which
seats
we speak with the unlv professor to
break down what will happen with
redistricting this summer and what
republicans and democrats are hoping to
get out of it
you're watching politics now
welcome back the 2020 census numbers are
in and soon nevada lawmakers are going
to hold a special session to redraw the
lines of congressional district so here
is what the map looks like right now for
the congressional districts here in
nevada and the idea is to get an equal
number of people in each district based
on the census so you can see here for
example the population deviation from
ideal this mark here is congresswoman
susie lee's district and this
is congresswoman titus as you can see
the difference there in the populations
the bottom line is redistricting will
sort of even those numbers out every 10
years the census and the legislature
sort out the boundaries of the
congressional legislative districts to
try and make sure it's even and fair
but it's just like a bill both houses
have to pass it then the governor signs
it we spoke with unlv political science
assistant professor dan lee about this
process
how much is nevada going to change from
an electoral process from a government
process from a representative process
10 years on how different does nevada
look right now so i think in terms of
representation the big question in terms
of redistricting is out of the four
seats how many are going to be
represented by democrats versus
republicans right because on the one
hand you look at nevada where swing
state you know the statewide elections
are all pretty competitive it's close to
50 50 split also just looking at party
registration of voters so you might
expect well if it's 50 50 then democrats
you get two republicans should get two
that seems like the most fair option or
most fair outcome
right but this is where
you know people start talking about
gerrymandering and you know kind of the
dirty side of redistricting um because
democrats are you know they currently
have a three to one advantage and
they're going to try to uh shore up that
advantage so they're going to try to
redraw the districts
that uh probably makes the third
district for instance a little bit safer
for susie lee republican in the state
legislature they're going to fight
against that redistricting plan
right and they're going to try to keep
it closer to a 202 split right or at
least keep it where some of these
districts such as the third district are
still in play for
republicans how do you envision her just
based on
what we have so right now
will how will the districts be
redrawn what's that battle going to be
like one way we can think about this
it's just an analogy where we need to
make a jigsaw puzzle out of nevada right
that's essentially what redistricting is
we have the picture of nevada and we're
just trying to cut it up into uh some
jigsaw pieces so we got to cut it up
into four pieces
right so
so there are constraints right it's not
where democrats republicans just can
just do whatever they want
right so for instance um
you know these jigsaw each jigsaw piece
is one congressional district so you
can't have like two separate jigsaw
pieces being represented by one
representative by one person right
so they have to be contiguous
another thing is they have to be compact
they can't be too big and sprawly and
weird shape although you do see weird
shape districts yeah that's like one of
the constraints right and you need to
respect um communities of interest so by
that you don't really want to split up
counties or cities like where you can
you try to keep people uh that have a
similar economic and political interest
together in the same congressional
district right so with those constraints
we can kind of see you know look ahead
of you know what's going to happen in
this next round of redistricting where a
lot of it's going to look the same it's
just shading enough to
secure what is already in place versus
gaining anything i don't think there's
any expectation by the democrats of
trying to take uh
mark emmett
right exactly right because again there
are constraints right again
there's limits to what the jigsaw pieces
can look like so again that's going to
leave the northern you know amadeus seat
you know relatively safer for him right
and
yes the you know democrats currently
again have a three to one advantage
right three house seats to one to amides
but i think what the democrats are going
to try to do is try to make the third
and fourth districts a bit more safe
right third district again you know heck
controlled that you know held that seat
for a while um and the horseback laws
re-election back in 2014 right so those
are districts that could swing either
way
so that's the big thing that democrats
are going to try to do is yes they have
a three to one advantage let's try to
make it a safer advantage right and the
way of doing that is siphoning off you
know moving voters from titus's first
district which is heavily democratic
because she has votes to spare and
giving moving some of those voters into
susie lee's district or horse for
district
changing the name of mccarran airport is
going to be expensive a couple of
million dollars so money is being raised
to turn it into harry reid international
airport and this week the fundraising
got a very big boost former sports
gambler business owner and one time
convicted felon billy walters kicked in
a million dollars to the cause he says
it's because the former senator is an
outspoken advocate of opportunity
village where walters son gets ov
services walters was pardoned in january
by former president donald trump after
being convicted for insider trading the
airport name change being paid for by
private donors that'll do it for
politics now we'll see you next week for
more details 8newsnow.com take care